Hall of Fame broadcaster NBC Sunday
Night Football play-by-play voice Al
Michaels joining us here in the Rich
Eisen studios on the campus of AT&T we
were talking about the Ohio State
they're trying to trademark the B in the
Ohio State do you remember the first
time you heard a player say that he was
from the Ohio State on Sunday Night
Football oh it had to be back in the 80s
and everybody I guess they're ingrained
with that when they go to Columbus and
they're told is the Ohio State
University I want you to know that when
I was growing up in Brooklyn I went to
thee PS 139 yes I did okay on Cortelyou
Road so and then of course I heard you
guys talking about before guys from
Miami call it the you I love that one I
love that and I mean Terrell Suggs had
an interesting take on Arizona State my
favorite though was I think Ike Taylor
the cornerback for Pittsburgh and he
used to come on Ike Taylor swaggin
swaggin no idea where Ike went to school
but but Taylor swagger like Taylor
swaggin been rejected for what they've
said if they were it happened when they
were taping it so we would not have see
I'm sure somebody did say something okay
but the guys have now evolved from the
school itself and by the way notice that
the offensive lineman for the most part
are very right down the middle they're
straight down the middle
they say exactly where they went to
school with you know a university or a
college of the University of of
proceeding it the linemen are very
straight the the receivers will give you
just about anything I'm waiting for the
guy one time though to come out of the
air who went to school in Oxford
Mississippi and calls it Mississippi
because we all know it is Ole Miss yeah
and I can't think of anybody who's ever
called at the University of Mississippi
is just Ole Miss so what do you think of
the Ohio State University he's
entertaining you know at first it was
like pretentious for this part of the
deal right yeah I laugh in it I cringe
when other players say like yeah
the University of Washington you know
they're mocking it yeah
did you trademark do you believe in
miracles no because I didn't think about
doing anything like and by the way those
are just words that are in the
dictionary and I put them together and
they were appropriate to that moment but
I think you have to go through a whole
process and who cares at this point what
was I supposed to do with it what would
you have said if you didn't say do you
believe in miracles
I would have said do you believe in
debacles if they would have watched the
game you mean they would have lost a
feeling because whatever you hear Jim
Nantz
Jim Nantz will have something to say at
a gust oh sure somebody wins or it's a
college basketball champion totally have
you ever scripted what you were gonna
say at the end of the game no and I
didn't there and part of the reason is
it would sound like it was rehearsed
yeah and I know I think Jim does a great
job at the end of it he's had some
fantastic lines at the end of the
masters I don't think he he goes in
there any scripts it it evolves maybe it
comes into your brain as the tournament
is winding down and clearly I try to
think of something maybe toward the end
of the game all I know is in Lake Placid
the only thing that came into my head
was the word miraculous and I got very
lucky because that game could have ended
let's say with the Soviets a shot on
goal could have tied the game and they
were putting some pressure on in the USN
and I was allowed to have those extra
couple of seconds when the puck came at
the center ice they cleared the punch
the puck came out to center ice we know
with five seconds to go in the game the
Soviets were not going to score so the
word in my brain was miraculous I'm
lucky in the sense that sometimes words
just come into your head we you know you
were there I did the New England Seattle
Super Bowl where Malcolm Butler
intercepts the pass at the goal line at
the end of the game and just out of my
heart I think the only thing I could say
was unreal because that was the emotion
that was like wow did that really
happen so unreal just sums it up as
opposed to your making up something that
sounds scripted and what you feel dated
as surprised if not more surprised than
Russell Wilson yes yes yeah I mean that
was that was a natural emotional
reaction I mean one if one word could
have some that if that was unreal
biggest I mean it was unreal the way the
game made it was unreal that the past
got thrown over the middle of was unreal
at Malcolm Butler who was a backup
defensive back made the interception
there's so many components to that but
instead of coming up with a pure
sentence or whatever or something that
you you had thought out of before him
kind of let your heart play out and I've
always tried to do that aside from the
do you believe in miracles do you have a
signature moment that you reflect back
on and say I I did my job as well as I
could possibly do well you know I've
been lucky in that I've done a lot of
unbelievable games I've made the last
four Super Bowls I've done have gone
down to the end of the game I mean
Arizona Pittsburgh I was talking about
that yesterday I said Ben doesn't get
enough credit for I think the signature
two-minute drill and not only that I
think the signature play I mean the
number one play I've ever seen is James
Harrison 100-yard interception return at
the end of the half yeah Arizona's going
into I mean he's got to be exhausted
Arizona's running a hurry up he's he's
got to be gas he's running down the
sideline he he barely stays inbounds
Larry Fitzgerald trying to chase him he
has to go through his own players I
think I said something like you know he
ran through the entire state of Arizona
and then you know falls into the end
zone as the clock goes to their triple
zeros so they don't even get to kick a
field goal if he goes out of bounds at
the half yard line yeah so I mean at the
Santonio Holmes catch the Roethlisberger
Drive fantastic unbelievable that game
was phenomenal Asst and the fact that
Arizona was even there everybody's
saying you know what are they doing here
they were they were beating something
like what 50 to nothing but New England
December so here they come and and you
know look that's Larry Fitzgerald that
is great a postseason as anybody's ever
had
ever and I believe he had a good Pro
Bowl as well so here five games in a row
where he was spectacular how do you call
a preseason game and he is it any
different than your approach to a
regular okay it is because especially
that the Hall of Fame game is vastly
different we did that a week and a half
ago there the players are not going to
be the players you're going to see on
opening day of the regular season also
in that game the great thing about it is
that it's a great showcase for Michele
Tafoya be she gets down on the field and
she talks to all of the inductees and
then we were able to bring John Elway up
into the booth we brought together so up
into the booth who got the Roselle award
and we had Tony Dungy so it's kind of
become as Jim Nantz might say a
tradition unlike any other we bring
Dungey into the booth in the third
quarter to take the pressure off in the
Hall of Fame game because at that point
you're talking about guys who are not
going to be on the team there's no
strategy involved zero it's a high
school stadium or a small college
Stadium it's a beautiful stadium that
they built in in in Canton and
refurbished the Tom Benson Hall of Fame
staney but still it it's it's not a
regular football game by any stretch of
the imagination I heard you talking
about you guys are talking about the
ratings of football games every season
the one I remember the most in 2000 I
think 9 so the preseason schedule came
out and we have Chicago at Denver like
week three which is the premium week so
to speak of the preseason and then about
a month after we see that we have that
game what happens Jay Cutler got traded
to Chicago and now Chicago is gonna come
back into Denver so that was I don't
know what the rating was I think that
was 2009 whatever it was you know we're
talking about how many people watch
preseason football it's the number one
show people love the NFL but you and I
know that I'm a perspective guy I live
by the rule of 330 million you know in
accounting there's the rule of 78 in
banking I live by the rule of 330
million if 8 million people are watching
a game 320 10 million people are not
watching the game
let's just keep this in perspective
right what's your biggest story line
going into this season I think well I
mean the Patriots are always a great
storyline can they do it again we're not
into the Browns will this I don't know
you know we have them week three against
the Rams the only thing I'll say about
the Browns is that sometimes the
expectations are over the moon and they
are and people now expect Cleveland to
be really really really good I mean if
they you go eight and eight that's gonna
be a disappointing season to Brown's
fans obviously nine and seven mm-hmm ten
and six okay let's see we going in the
playoffs so obviously with Mayfield and
with Beckham and Landry and a new coach
and I don't know how it's gonna play out
but I do think going into the season
that is one of the great storylines
I think CBS says the opening day game I
was talking to our buddy Nance yesterday
they've got Tennessee at Cleveland we go
in there with the Rams that Cleveland in
Week three we'll know a lot about that
team early I think have you sat down
with Baker Mayfield
I have not I've not met him so when you
afford these team meetings yes who's
involved in those team meetings well on
our side as you know Fred Goodell in
Jurassic got producer director but what
do you ask for from a team or what are
they we always get the head coach and
the quarterback even Belichick oh yeah a
bunch of comes to every meeting we have
Belichick we have that we have
occasionally we'll have a coordinator if
nothing else and Chris will talk to the
coordinator separately and talk about
certain things and then he brings that
to our production meeting on Sunday
morning so amongst us we'll talk to just
about everybody we need to talk to and
then we'll ask for you know three or
four or five players who are germane to
the game and we know are like good
talkers like for instance with all the
years we did Baltimore had had we had to
have rail oeis and they had to have subs
in it he was going at it read in there
so sometimes there are teams with a lot
of guys you want to bring in the
offensive linemen are terrific we do the
Rams you put Andrew Whitworth in he's
great I mean it's really smart and gets
it and understands everything
probably be a coach someday if he's not
a broadcaster
those are the guys you look for you look
for a guy who's funny witty you look for
a guy who's controversial I mean we had
I I give Beckham a lot of credit when we
went into New York on a couple of
occasions and he's playing with the
Giants I mean he's in the crosshairs and
he's all over the place but we asked for
him sometimes they turn us down but he
would always show up and you know and he
would address the issue if you were
giving a seminar for the NFL on people
who want to go into the business and be
an analyst like what would you tell them
this is what you need to work on this is
what I'm looking for you're talking
about a player coming off the field or a
coach yeah what I tell these guys and
I've talked to a number of them through
the years one on one is look we know you
know football the the business of
broadcasting is not an X's and O's
business you can't sit there and do a
clinic because you can analyze every
play to the enth degree but just keep
look at the whole game look at the going
to a game and go what is this game about
inside the game will be each of these
plays which you can diagram and and
discuss and you can do it to a degree
that somebody who has not played the
game can do it but what is what did this
what are the storylines Stan is one of
the master you know this as well as
anybody you know what what are the
issues what are we looking at here what
players are we looking at what does this
mean in the in terms of the standings or
the future of the franchise or whatever
it is but find something and then always
keep that in mind well timing to of
getting in getting out being precise
right right and you know I look I work
with a guy who is as good as anybody
who's ever done it Chris Collinsworth
and you know Chris extremely well and he
has the ability to not only get in and
get out and be concise but see things
that people don't see but you see it in
real time
yeah what I'm always amazed is then he
comes right back and then tells you this
is what happened it's fascinating that
that's really hard a lot of that
is his preparation uh he studies as much
as anybody he also has pro Football
Focus so he's involved in that I mean
he's consumed by this during the season
so he the reason he's able to do that in
good measure is because he's
anticipating it so he can't anticipate
everything but once in a while he'll
think about he sees a matchup on the
line with this lineman is getting beaten
by that lineman and he'll keep his eye
on that and sure enough I mean he called
a sack in it at the end of a game I
think in in New Orleans between the
Chargers and the Saints a few years back
which was phenomenal nobody's looking
for this bang it happened he said if the
the tackle doesn't you know he's gonna
get beat again and it's gonna end the
game I remember oh yeah I said to my
boss at NBC I said Collinsworth just won
the sports Heming right yeah on that
play he could I said he just won the
sports anyway on that play put that on
the on the reel so that are we are we
looking for the next Tony Romo like it's
a copycat yeah but I mean everybody's in
individualist like saying I'm looking
for the next John Madden John really
changed the template but babies in the
70s and the 60s before that the analyst
was the pure analyst and and he the
football at in those years the fans
didn't know half as much as they know
now but he would he would take you in
not John I'm saying the guys in the 70s
for the most part because that's the way
you did the game then John came in and
you know did the sound effects and and
all the things that people loved in
addition to being a phenomenal analyst
but then what John did is he spawned a
lot of imitators and bad imitators
through the years everybody then coming
up through those years was trying to be
the next John Madden there's only one
John Madden period and to me you know
look Romo is fantastic
Tony's different you can't try to be
Tony Romo you can't try to be Cris
Collinsworth yeah but you could get a
quarterback I I still think if Payton
ever did this I would have Payton cam
where he walks you to the line of
scrimmage I got a camera behind the
quarterback yep Payton is taking
in real time and just surveying the
situation and I think that that would be
unbelievable football well you would do
that but let's say Peyton's doing a game
and Peyton would be great if he ever
decides to go into this business you
have 125 130 plays a game yeah how often
do you want to do that well I think you
pick your moments let's say 37 or
redzone
okay this one I'm seeing Mike Leinbach
are there oh I got a mismatch over here
right I'm worried about this safety
right here and then you do the
play-by-play you come in and then say I
third and seven for Brady sure and then
you know you describe the action come
back and then Peyton you know be great
stripes it's no question but again a
handful of times almost during the game
because a lot of plays don't compel you
to go there you've been do it yeah yeah
so can you stay for the final segment
can I stay I don't know the traffic
clear are you gonna check the traffic
here no hold on I'm gonna check the
market right now the Dow's of 40 in the
Nash six down seven and a half how's
your inverted yield curve doing by the
way
what's the best day you ever had in the
market just save that we'll come back
okay you've got alright we'll come back
we'll finish up the show here on this
Thursday with Al Michaels back after
this the best day you've had in the
market can you tell us I can't why
please I don't want the authorities at
my door oh no I know I've had you know
good day said two days ago was great
yesterday was terrible yeah you didn't
laugh when I said the inverted yield
curve hold on one second let's get an
update yeah 53 but the Nasdaq is down
two questions about the Danites okay
number one who is the Baba Booey of this
group Baba Booey nobody answers okay
Ritchie's that you know all right sue
well you guys decide that fritzy fritzy
probably would be very you Baba Booey
from the Howard Stern Show and you and
you as the boss yeah what would you do
if these guys wanted to unionize that
seems too
that seems to be the deal these days
right guys this day in sports I'm back
[Laughter]
Lynn Swann is gonna join us in studio
smart my old partner and Willie McGinest
will stop by the man cave this day in
sports history quickly in 1993 Nolan
Ryan got his 324th and final victory in
this day in Al Michaels history two
years ago at Toscana he had the 26 ounce
prime t-bone steak if you're in tina is
that correct though that would be
correct yep right and a few potatoes on
the side was storage and probably
started with some pasta fazool
that's correct we complain this day in
sports history putts you my Continental
Tire they want you to arrive to the game
safely so they can remind you to take
five minutes at the beginning of every
month to check your tire pressure you
can learn more about the great products
at Continental Tire dot-com did you ever
work on your voice not really you know
when I was a kid and I wanted to do this
and I'm announcing sports on the campus
station at Arizona State I hated my
voice
but are you better now these are voice
better now
I'm older so it sounds deeper I mean my
wife will watch something that I did 35
years ago and will say that's not even
you and it doesn't sound like me to me
but it was me and then you know you get
older and you know I smoked for a while
- but that's 30 years ago so maybe that
had something to do with it I was able
to survive that nonsense because people
will ask well how do you get your voice
and I go I never thought neither did I
and I used to worry about it
be sure you wanted to have a deeper bass
for your voice when you were a kid you
know I sounded like a kid when I was
doing the games at at Arizona State and
so I would have
yearned for a better deeper voice but
that just comes along naturally best
voice belongs to who the best voice yeah
Freddie Mercury okay announcer okay
alright you got me on that okay sarah
vaughan okay
brokenhearted Marilyn melody now now
we're aging ourselves aren't we Harry
Kalas Harry K Harry Kalas preceded me as
the voice of the Hawaii Islanders in the
60s believe it or not yes she did Harry
Kalas nice six degrees of separation
here with them right Harry did I'm
there's some great voices uh
I mean ray Scott had a tremendous guy
right
Curt Goudy Curt Goudy that sounded like
sports I loved Curt Gowdy Keith Jackson
Keith Jackson yeah like you hear a voice
and that's what's great now would Cosell
reporting from the Dan Patrick show hard
by the Rich Eisen studios here in El
Segundo
where the buzz around the offices the
boys are trying the jimmy hoffa the
fourth Wolverine to try to trademark of
is in the University of Michigan
McLovin would you learn ow my khals has
some great advice for the day Annette's
it's time to fight the power
Paulie we're bringing in Al Michaels as
our union delegate and seat no come shop
steward Paul past well try to figure out
what the inverted yield curve might be
what we learn brought to you by TBS home
for baseball and Sunday Dodgers in the
Braves at 1:00 Eastern my thanks to the
great Al Michaels for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]